how are you guys doing I was here doing
in and I met mallah a very famous person
a celebrity who has converted to Islam
uh and she's from Ghana aren't you tell
us what you used to do before and what
made you come to
Islam I used to be a videoan yeah photo
model and also um an actress and a
singer as well I've done
movies
side and the music videos some of the
musicians have like a Nollywood has
something like Nollywood gwood called
gwood gwood
yeah okay so I through my photo shoot I
used to doed photo shoots and I did one
with my son that was 2020 30th June his
birthday and that brought me into a big
problem that landed me
it was the help
of and then the president of Ghana and
then the Attorney General of Ghana they
help me they sentenced me they they got
me out and they sent me again and then
finally
they sure so after I when I was facing
my trials yeah the my brothers the
Muslims my brothers Muslims and sisters
me I'm not saying the Christians but the
Love Came one of my Muslim friend she
came to
sleep come in theay there were
feeding
wow
Ghana we get that one yes when you the
next time you come to Ghana I'll give
you Ghana uh-huh the is it good like the
Nigerian one or is it better it's better
than okay fine you he that
first with P not you enjoy it so after
that when I was growing up I agree with
Muslims my friends were all Muslims and
my mom told me before that two of my
uncles convered to Islam
before so my mom wasn't um surprised at
all what what made you what about the
Rel of Islam in particular attracted you
about it so you said okay you're the
people the the brothers and sisters they
gave you good support but was there
anything else no in Islam I see peace
and unity yes and I used to be Christian
when I go to church yeah though they
said Allah Look Into the Heart of human
M um I didn't see that Christian could
te me down to me but since I joined
Islam MH there are some things that I
used to do before I used to be loud I
talk about people issue I'll be there
I'll wear transparent things I'll be
dancing twerking on social media it can
cause issues the Kings and the chiefs of
Ghana will be calling on me on radios
they at a point they said I should
change the name of aim po because aim is
a name of one of the cities in Ghana
and so I'm polo polo is a food
so I said
I'm so because of my behavior the chief
ordered me to stop using the people I
didn't listen to I had issue with the
with with the so do you think Islam gave
you discipline then very that is what I
want to see yeah that what very because
Islam has really T me down I sometimes I
feel like even putting on something put
on camera on me then no I won't post it
even if I try doing the video I I can't
post it I will move I can never put on
anything transparent showing my hands
outside how do you feel praying here in
Mecca and what was your experience like
you came here for omra and prayers as
well how did you feel about it when I
was coming I didn't know the feeling so
when I got here that night they said we
have to go
and when I got there I saw a l people I
was like where from these people why mhm
because the crowd I or it's more than 1
billion yeah and no country no religion
can hold such this is serious Crow of
and everyone everyone is one everyone is
wearing the same thing his CL white clo
but everyone is disciplined yes no one
ising I'm bigger than you I'm richer
than you I have to sit here and you have
to sit here you know in in Christian
religion if you have money you have to
sit in Fr the rich people have where to
sit and the poor people like not that
poor you know that is how they arrange
in the church that
where so yeah it's not like that
everyone sits the same place just that
is in Islam they don't mix women with
men so in Islam the women we will be
um in front sometimes and then the men
depends how AR sometimes the
men so I'm still learning just converted
one
andah yes I'm still Lear that's really
good you've done really well for
yourself I have to say and do you think
that because you've seen both kind of
lives you've seen the disciplined
spiritual life of Islam believing and
worshiping one God because Islam I mean
for people that don't know what Islam is
that are watching this from Ghana and
from West Africa from Africa from where
else in the world um you need understand
that Islam is a religion where we only
believe in one God yeah we believe in
Abraham and Moses and Jesus we believe
that all of these prophets came with
only one message which is to believe in
one God and to be good to your fellow
man so we don't believe for example like
Christians believe that Jesus was God
himself we don't believe that he was
part of the Trinity we don't believe in
the Holy Spirit was God but that the
Trinity is true so this is the main
difference between Islam and
Christianity because we would say why is
it the case that you have a man who's
God anyway how could you have a man
that's God because a man is limited and
God is unlimited God is the creator of
the heavens and the Earth whereas a man
he had a beginning anyone with a date of
birth cannot be God Jesus had a date of
birth therefore Jesus could not be God
but we believe in Jesus we believe that
he's the Messiah we believe that he's a
prophet We believe We respect him we
respect Mary his mother so this these
are the main differences between
Christianity and Islam from a
theological perspective but I was going
to ask you now imagine if people because
you obviously you're in touch with the
younger Generations I you're very much
you know genz and Millennials they' know
your work and they know what you're
about especially in your area do you
think if more people took the turn that
you took done the thing that you done
which is become a Muslim Embrace
discipline spiritual and physical
Discipline Do you think that the world
would be a better place that Ghana would
be a better place it will with what I
saw at the where the cover is where I
went to do
my
discipline Islam the r is so if like
Christian and the other religion are all
my English is no it's very good
fantastic I are able to come together
and worship
us Muslims oh like the whole world will
be peaceful very peaceful they used to
say that in Islam there's no peace for
when I join and I don't think anything
going to take me back sometimes my
sisters my friends they say those one
please so don't let anything take you
back or don't let me Islam religion is
something that I've been Destin
you I have a son and the father is Islam
and by then I I was over there I wasn't
in the industry
somewhere so that should tell you that
Islam I love
Islam and I don't want my son to grow up
because if I should be Christian where I
go is because my son is with me so if
I'm going to church son we used to go to
church but my son is Islam the father is
Muslim so I want to bring him up in
thisam so that when he grw up and he saw
me I want to be Christian that is his
own decision but I will show back if my
son should come and should grow up and
ask me why you knew my dad is this
Muslim and he took me to church and he
will be so disappointed in so myself
since I'm interested in the Islamic
ReliOn I I took the lead I thought of
taking the lead going to Mo and going to
the teachings listening to Islam
religion teaching with my son so that
when he grew up he shouldn't you lived
the life before you became Muslim you
were saying half nak pictures you know
dancing you know acting whatever it may
be and you've seen all this kind of
thing did that give you
happiness it didn't give me happiness
because each and every day that I post
something I know that this that that I'm
going to post they will give me insults
radio stations yes it what kind of
insults like I have been a trome person
on social media yeah yes for you if you
have an issue I'll pick on you like if
you get married at for instance I would
just say that oh you got married because
your wife is pregnant oh I see and then
defaming your so you've been defamed
before yes that is what I've been doing
to people and so after aside that I do B
pictures yes and when I do it it
trains any time I do it it goes bar
depending on how I do it and I wear
transparent something and then I will be
twerking and I post it so I was causing
problem yes and I got attention of the
president even the president mhm the
Chiefs and even outside the country the
celebrities outside the country because
here's a here's the thing like many
people um many women across the world
and some men of course but mostly it's a
female dominated industry would would
post things like that would post sexual
pictures and stuff and there's a
difference between influence and
fame okay because some people think okay
if they get 100,000 views they get a
million views that means influence but
really that person being used as sorry
to say a pornographic entity like a
handkerchief it's only that the person
doesn't care about you know so what I'm
trying to say is that when you leave
that life that right you're no longer
being used as an object yes and and and
now you're a human being again yeah and
now some at face some businesses and
some companies didn't want to work with
me because they say that I'm not good
for brand with what I've been doing and
some of the celebrities were even saying
that because of things that I do I'm not
good for their brand they can't shoot a
movie with me sometimes contracts will
come I will know that the producer will
send the script to me and then he will
let me know the celebrities on board
later on I will see the movie showing
and I'm not I see yes sometimes some
companies wouldn't want to work with me
because of
my but since I stopped all this for the
past two years now that I stopped all
these things if look at the big man that
came mhm yes at first he will not come
to me because I'm too loud and no right
person no one in their right senses will
come close to and a behavior like that
because everyone cheres their
reputations and yes so now that I'm Cal
I'm able to enter some places that those
days I'm not able to enter and when they
call big people will call me to do some
brands that were giv me money because
some like skare products because I was
exposed they were coming but some big
big companies like phone shops and like
phones and big big Brands not able to
come but now they are building
building estate developers now they work
with me at first they don't work you
know the prophet told us Prophet
Muhammad told us that if you do
something to try and please the people
but it displeases
Allah then Allah makes the people
displeased with you and he becomes
displeased with you whereas if you do
something which it's displeasing to
Allah it displeasing to the people but
it's pleasing Allah then Allah makes the
people please with you and Allah pleased
with you that's your story is a
beautiful example of that because now
you have a whole family of two billion
people the Muslim people
brothers and sisters who don't see you
just as some kind of pornographic entity
or to relieve their desires they see you
as a human being with ideas who they
have genuine love for that they want to
be connected to that they would
protect you you're more than just the
numbers on the screen or 100,000 200
million people whatever it may be but
they don't care about now you're part of
a family and uh something else I wanted
to say to you is that when you become
Muslim all of your sins in the past have
been
removed this is you know like you have
Born Again Christians we also as Muslims
when you become Muslim and you say
shahada the same idea applies so
anything you've done in the past whether
it's half naked pictures whether it's
even worse than this anything you've
done even if you kill somebody we
believe that Allah he removes and cleans
cleanses all of your purifies all of
your sins and you become like a newborn
baby so you don't have to think about
your previous life now this is New Life
alhamdulillah what Sometimes some things
bother me a lot especially the picture I
took with my son I've been taken when he
goes up well that was all all you will
say to him is that was in my past and
this is my future some of the greatest
people and figures in Islamic history
had a horrible past but then they became
good Muslims and no one remembers them
for the bad they only remember them for
the good like the companions of the
Prophet some of them the prophet's
friends some of them they had hard lives
you know they were a bit like gangsters
and these kind of things and doing Haram
things but then they became Muslim and
all of their sins are removed in fact
even the sins can become good
deeds so you don't have to worry about
that inshallah now you are fresh and
clean like a new SL with that guys uh we
are going to conclude because we need to
pray and do other things but thank you
so much s for for that thank you too
thank this is like a Dre because I've
been watching you on YouTube a lot I
follow you programs and I I didn't know
a day like this will come I'm so blessed
well I'm I'm blessed as well for having
met you and to hear your story is very
inspirational to be honest it's very
powerful guys make sure um mallah if
anyone attacks our sister online or
tries to say a bad word about her spread
me bad messages especially the brothers
and sisters in West Africa for following
that you defend our sister because this
is our duty to defend our sister to
defend everybody as the Quran
says that Muslim men and women are all
allies